we saw a few troops on the ground in
chibok
despite assurances that there are
thousands here
engaged in a hunt for the missing school
girls
instead the soldiers most of whom didn't
want to be filmed
complained about their conditions their
pay and the lack of support from the
authorities
one chose to speak out we're not
identifying him for his own safety
that is our problem in nigeria we get no
equipment
much of the equipment does not work the
weapon the soldiers use is the ak-47
you need something more powerful yes
they will give soldiers two magazines
so we need something that is more
powerful and that we can use for a
longer time before it's finished
the boko haram leader has been filmed
standing in front of military vehicles
his fighters are well armed and have
been mistaken for soldiers by many of
their victims
they recruit through a mixture of force
and promises of great riches
they frightened me did all what they
could to intimidate me to join them
and they promised me that if i join them
they will give me a lot of money
if boko haram orders aren't followed
through then the villagers get the same
treatment as the chibok girls
wanton vandalism and violent killings or
kidnappings
and to the frustration of nigerian
citizens the army and police seem
reluctant to take them on
alhaji ali hassan lost three of his
brothers
in an attack on their village 12 days
ago
the truth of the matter is that there is
nothing we can do we cannot defend
ourselves
this these guys have all kinds of guns
the army that are supposed to protect us
they are very close by
very close by but they refuse to come
and defend us so what can we do there is
nothing we can do
our anonymous soldier was terrified when
fellow soldiers turned up at our meeting
point trying to find him
he hid inside whilst the soldier stood
outside
and others searched for him he said he
faced torture in jail if the army found
out he'd spoken to us
but that many in the army felt just like
him
we soldiers we're trying our best and
civilians don't know we're trying our
best
they don't know what weapons the army's
giving us to go and fight boko haram
they don't know the caliber of weapons
the nigerian army is giving us
the nigerian authorities insist they're
doing everything they can to find and
release the girls
but with what seems to be an
increasingly disgruntled army
it's not proving easy alex crawford
sky news in borno northern nigeria